shall we go for it
[Music]
if you close your eyes ariana grande
might fool you because she's proven yet
again she's the queen of celebrity
impressions thank you the thank you next
singer is at it again this time on tick
tock channeling her inner pilot
prepare for launch
flight crew prepare for launch
seems like the 28 year old can go all
day with accents as she imitates famous
stars including legally blonde's
jennifer coolidge
i'm taking the dog
dumbass
glitter all over my face goddamn
how did that even get there
so much pigment i'm [ __ ] drowning in
pigment and get this jennifer is a fan
back in january she said thanks to ari's
impression her career got a boost
i sort of you know
i was going through a dead zone and um
you know
not much was going on and then
ariana did this imitation on your show
and you encouraged her and um and then
this ball got rolling but it's ari's
impression of celine dion that continues
to make our jaws drop like crew i wanted
to take a moment to um
thank you for giving me the chance to
perform for you wow what a treat shall
we go for it
[Music]
it's too good i need to see it again
like crew i wanted to take a moment to
um
thank you for giving me the chance to
perform for you wow what a treat shall
we go for it
[Music]
but ari fans know it's hardly the first
time she's flexed her saline impression
skills
and my shoes and i got a blue blue
sweatshirt
sorry i i've spent a little too much
time watching her four-hour documentary
celine through the eyes of the world
i know every word it was a real surprise
and sometimes the most impressive
impression the one you can do of your
bff
yeah at the drop of a hat ari can go
straight into liz gillies mode without
even saying a word who else can i do
this gillies
yep that's ari perfectly nailing liz
signature expression
no
captain says denied
but you can't you can't just read the
phone tori
so yeah whether ari is giving us celine
shall we go for it
[Music]
jennifer
glitter all over my face god damn
how did that even get there
so much pigmen
drowning in pigment or simply imitating
her bff liz
no
safe to say ari takes the crown as the
queen of impressions she shut the [ __ ]
up already
[Music]
you